it will be necessary to do a spoiler
talk video for Avengers endgame but this
is not that video this is not that time
this is a spoiler free review so peace
of mind there that said if this comes
across his vague if it comes across to
me just being like well I like things
and then there was a thing and but
another thing was cool and that
character was high I just try not to
spoil it I said let's talk about this
movie that's the culmination of the past
eleven years of the MCU
[Music]
Avengers endgame so Avengers endgame is
the sequel to Avengers infinity war yes
Avengers endgame is in fact three hours
long Avengers infinity Wars like two and
a half or something like that so really
it's one five and a half hour epic at
the end of Avengers infinity war
spoilers if you haven't seen it I
imagine you have Thanos went snap and
half of living beings disappeared so now
this movie is them picking up the scraps
if I would say life but really general
existence that's a big hit everything
took so now they got to lick their
wounds help each other up
take out Thanos if they can bring
everyone back who disappeared if they
can and that's really as much as I can
say about it because that's what the
trailer showed there's more going on in
this movie there's always three hours
long by the runtime you know it's not as
simple as well gotta take that hose down
I guess so the trailers were really
vague it doesn't show really what's
going on so I can't talk about what's
really going on because if I talk about
what's not in the trailer as people see
it as a spoiler so we'll just talk about
how I felt about the movie I really
enjoyed the hell out of it I mean it'd
be in three hours long there are slow
parts slow parts those slow parts are
character building parts I loved them
all I was never bored in this movie for
a three hour long movie to not bore me
that's impressive
it really does some great things with
characters because where everyone's
experiencing some form of pain or loss
it's not like they're like ah humanity
disappeared cool well let's go take down
the grimace it's not that simple man
this fall out there great character
moments come from that like Hawkeye is
more interesting in this movie that
needs ever been in any MCU movie ever I
mean it like I mean it I mean granted
Hawkeye's character doesn't have a lot
of competition when it comes to
Hawkeye's character but no he was quite
ravenous movie Captain America gets more
shine that was one of my disappointments
with Infinity Ward's like Captain
America I felt like that kind of pushed
to whose side I was like no that it's
cap come on he became a favorite cap
gets more time to shine in here I
appreciated that I will say this isn't
fan OSIS movie like infinity Wars Thanos
this movie for sure this is not that
this is the Avengers movie like Thanos
had his movie he not punched all of them
now it's them on the ground clutching
their nuts good yeah that hurt didn't it
okay let's let's see you try to get
through that you're gonna punch back
cool all right
is your moment now cameras on you
clutching your balls on the ground so if
Thanos made infinity war for you'd like
endgame isn't gonna give you that same
feeling for that out I will say there
are moments of conflicting information
or at least one in particular where I'm
like before you said now it works that's
that's conflicting I don't know just
things it's like Thor taking a dying
star to the chest Lord can he really do
that I guess he took it to the back
it came whatever they used Captain
Marvel really well - I know Captain
Marvel's like a hot topic like a
hot-button topic right now there's like
some weird Captain Marvel economy online
if you make videos about Captain Marvel
apparently that's just good for YouTube
videos I don't know why people care that
much but I guess they do but they used
Captain Marvel really well in this movie
in fact in this movie I concede in this
movie where I'm like oh you mean like
she really is powerful like this movie
made me like Captain Marvel more than
Captain Marvel's movie made me like
Captain Marvel but this is also directed
by the Russos so I think her better
director granted she's not in the movie
much so again if you're looking for like
oh yeah a Captain Marvel fest he's not
really that so when her sparingly being
in this movie when they did use her I
really liked part of the plot that I
actually can't talk about here because
you know it's not in the trailer and by
part of the plot I mean it's a big part
of it it's familiar to another movie
that I also can't mention here it's very
familiar I walked out going it is like
this movie you'll know when you see it
when you watch the movie you'll be like
that is like this other movie but as a
whole it all worked out and the last act
is really [ __ ] indescribable it's
indescribable that's how I can describe
it this is the MCU going yeah here it
here it is it's come to a head this is
11 years built to this guys in the end
that that's what I can say about this
movie this movie is that this movie is
the fanservice the payoff that the MCU
is giving the fans that have been here
for 11 years or if you haven't been here
for 11 years if you got on the train at
any point this movie it's here for you
like granted yeah if you're looking for
some highbrow masterpiece if you're all
like yes it is a movie but does it film
is it hot you might leave disappointed I
mean it's [ __ ] art as far as I'm
concerned but it's not like that it
embraces what it is and
it changes the game and it's almost when
I was driving home I was just thinking
to myself it's impossible to rate this
movie as a movie in and of itself it's
not a contained experience it's not just
this one movie it's not just one movie
it's chapter 22 of a saga and Odyssey a
legacy like if you come into Avengers
endgame you're select all right yeah I'm
loosey-goosey with the MCU some of its
alright I haven't seen all the movies
I'm gonna check this out and see how it
is you'll probably walk away going oh
yeah I had fun with it but if you've
been there for the MCU you love the MCU
you know the heroes you know the
villains you know the conflict you know
the strife you know the love you love
the characters you know the interactions
you know the relationships if you feel
connected to it in that capacity which I
personally do this movie was straight-up
made for you it's not literature like
Lord of the Rings but in its own right
it's pretty damn impactful I will say
Avengers end game is awesome tacular
alright spoiler-free i spoiler-free as i
could make it because i had to talk
about the damn movie like walking out of
the movie the trailers are so VAT goes
like I don't know what I could talk
about oh I can just go that doesn't
matter does it
that's not the spoiler alright it's
about this time I would say avengers
endgame what do you think is gonna
happen what do you think comment below
let me know not going to do that this
time because avengers endgame has been
seen and there are people out there who
know what happens in avengers endgame
some of those people work to spoil the
experience for people by giving spoilers
so there are probably spoilers in the
comments section right now don't even go
down there if you want to help the video
out give this video a thumbs up and then
just [ __ ] bounce stay off the
internet until you see Avengers end game
I'm serious don't come back until you
see it's been great I'll see you this
week and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]